the Joe Rogan experience that's a Kevin
Smith lead oh that's my dog laughter I'm
from the movie Jay lollipop yeah that's
his JimBob we with the UM with the UH
with the cartoon on the inside of it
yeah I was in that film I would sit [ __ ]
I know that dude yeah he's so dope he's
a great guy he is the best man he's I
work with him on something
a couple years ago and he said he was a
fan and he keeps [ __ ] caught him for
projects but he's so [ __ ] cool when
we were doing cuz people been on when we
did a show called Holly weed right we
played we were we owned a dispensary in
Hollywood it was a funny as pilot and it
was part of this rivet TV they had this
process where a lot of you know you
people do parties that never get
greenlit they lay the pilot and then you
you pledge if you want to get the pilot
the green light
okay company fell apart the [ __ ] on
the show did well we got Snoop Dogg
retweeted people enjoying it and um and
it just it just stopped
we just started but he was so [ __ ]
cool and we did Holly we reset and I
talked to me he said Donnie I'm at a
point in my life I'm at a stage in my
life where I'm not gonna do anything
unless as fun as what I want to do yeah
and that joint was post again we didn't
get a palpable it was a good time man
and he'd fill me up in on Jay and Sal
about reboot you know him pre we'd a new
oven pre we'd I met him pre we'd and
then the second or third time we hung
out he started smoking weed really I was
like what's going on
what what was that after you you have to
heart attack no no no no way before he
just went hard with weed like out of
nowhere he was like no weed and then all
we'd you know the creative people can
get oh and I know his strand is like a
hybrid sateen man
yeah but it was just interesting to know
him before when he wasn't smoking and
then
I mean he's just he's all day hi I'm
good
he's all day hi yeah he's one of those
dudes he's one of those like Wiz Khalifa
type dudes those uh it didn't just just
start pounding out right and [ __ ] yeah
we were we were working on Holly we we
got up to three other scripts and I
would just go up there and just chill
and I'm like I can't believe I'm
chilling with Kevin Smith and smoking a
joint and we're just talking and the
[ __ ] and the goddamn keyboard
is just going crazy yeah yeah he's a
genuine person very very good person
yep and then [ __ ] man he said off he did
things nobody ever done me just to
create a brand that could last for
[ __ ] 2025 an independent filmmaker
and it's like did you ever see that
movie red state that he did didn't you
ever see it was one of his best movies
as a weird man so strange because he
didn't tell me anything about it
because I just want you to see it so we
sat down we watched it and it was a
horror movie it's like it's a horror
suspense thriller movie it's not funny
at all doesn't try to be funny at all
but did he tell you that it didn't tell
me [ __ ] uh he literally didn't tell me
anything but I'm assuming it's a Kevin
Smith movie I'm assuming it's gonna be
fun you know but you know what they've
got me people like that you know
somewhere deep down inside a like I want
to do something [ __ ] different right
what people know me from
[Applause]